heute mich jemand habe mich verlaufen
können sie wenig zu marktplatz reilly
dominik grafs film die geliebten
schwestern zeigt den jungen friedrich
schiller in einem liebesdreieck im
sommer 1788 lernt der dichter zunächst
charlotte von lengefeld kennen
ihm gefällt dass charlotte jungen
mädchenhaft von henriette confurius
dargestellt ihm widerspricht alter nach
dem weg fragt aber sie an sich sind
nicht hier aber sie irren sich jetzt
hätten sie sich nicht verlaufen
es ist wahr aber nach dem prozess aus
falls sie unrecht haben komme ich wieder
bei ihm vorbei es über antwort sich als
sie den weg zurück zu mir finden
nachdem er ein kind vor dem ertrinken
rettet wärmen die schwestern den
splitternackten schiller mit ihren armen
und den riesigen fiel dagegen rücken
hannah herzsprung spielt voller
verlangen und lebenslust charlottes
ältere schwester caroline die bereits
verheiratet ist
ihr seid aufrecht das ist etwas anderes
berichten auch wenig verständnis sie
sich in der dünnen luft in weimar
gefallen sagten wir beide uns dort
kennengelernt gas film ist kultur
klassik und kulisse ihn kennzeichnet ein
überschuss an leidenschaft für alles was
darin vorkommt der regisseur über lässt
die figuren ihren gefühlen die sie ganz
offen aussprechen
die schwestern lieben einander über
alles mit dem jungen dichter genie
beginnt das glück zutritt liebe sie
beide
caroline kam von ihrer seite verteidigen
heißt friedrich und sein name ist doch
komplikationen bleiben nicht aus weil
dreiecks lieben für mindestens einen
dreierbund schwer auszuhalten sind in
diesem fall ist dass charlotte die den
jungen schiller ähnlich intensive lotte
in weimar bieten sie die heirat
ihr werdet glücklich wer nicht weiß das
wird mit uns ich habe nicht vor zu
verzichten und zum dank für großzügiges
luft kann ich ihn halt nach der
vertiefung unserer freundschaft anbieten
warum brauchen wir diesen film über zwei
frauen im ausgehenden 18 jahrhundert ein
mann der mit seiner dichtung unsterblich
wurde und ihre liebe zu dritt während
eines sommers weil die geliebten
schwestern einen reichtum an bildern und
empfindungen ins kino bringen die dort
nicht mehr oft zu finden sind